Las alarmas han vuelto a sonar en Kiev.
Y esta vez no ha sido exclusivamente por la
amenaza de nuevos ataques rusos.
Lo que está sonando en esta ocasión es la
alarma del tesoro nacional.
Porque querida comunidad, el gobierno de Ucrania
tiene las arcas prácticamente vacías.
Se está quedando sin dinero, lo que puede
tener no solo importantes consecuencias económicas
sino también militares.
Esto que os vamos a contar en este vídeo
es algo así como la otra cara del frente
de guerra.
Una cara indispensable pero que, sin embargo,
apenas recibe cobertura de los medios de comunicación.
Ucrania no solo está luchando contra Rusia,
también está lidiando con una enorme crisis
económica, monetaria y energética cuyas
repercusiones pueden ser enormes.
Pero...
¿Hasta qué punto corre Ucrania el riesgo
de quebrar?
¿Cuál es exactamente el daño que ha provocado
la invasión rusa?
¿Quién o quiénes están financiando realmente
el esfuerzo de la guerra?
Y quizás la pregunta más importante de todas:
¿qué puede suponer todo esto en el campo
de batalla?
Atentos.
Las cosas en el campo de batalla han mejorado
considerablemente para Ucrania.
Seis meses después de comenzar la invasión,
los rusos se encuentran prácticamente estancados.
Ahora su única ventaja se limita en la práctica
a su poderosa artillería, la cual sigue infligiendo
un terrible daño en el ejército y las ciudades
ucranianas.
La desproporción entre piezas de artillería
rusas y ucranianas en la primera línea de
combate sigue siendo enorme.
Y aquí la estrategia de Rusia es muy clara:
utilizar su enorme músculo artillero para
arrasar con todo a su paso y facilitar el
avance de la infantería.
Sin embargo, pese a ello, contra viento y
marea, los avances del ejército de Putin
se han detenido casi por completo.
La tenaz resistencia de los ucranianos y la
llegada de armamento occidental le ha dado
al ejército de Ucrania mucho más músculo,
y eso se nota.
N1 (Los ataques ucranianos en Crimea debilitan
la capacidad militar de Rusia.
Al Jazeera)
Pero esto corresponde al frente militar.
En este vídeo quere B mos centrar nuestra
atención en otro campo de batalla: lo que
podemos llamar el frente económico.
(La guerra iniciada por Rusia ha tenido consecuencias
devastadoras sobre el terreno y, también,
sobre la economía ucraniana.
Muchas fábricas han sido destruidas, las
infraestructuras están siendo muy castigadas
y muchas empresas han tenido que echar el
cierre.
Por ejemplo, según varias encuestas, la guerra
ha dinamitado cerca de la mitad de todos los
empleos del país, bien porque estos han desaparecido
bien porque los salarios y las horas trabajadas
se han desplomado.
Con datos de junio de 2022, y a pesar de la
movilización militar, la tasa de paro superaba
ya el 35%.
)
Fijaos por ejemplo en este mapa:
(Durante el verano del 2022, algo más del
20% de todo el territorio de Ucrania estaba
ocupado por Rusia o convertido en un sangriento
campo de batalla.
Estas son las regiones que veis en color azul
oscuro.
Pues bien este territorio suponía antes de
la guerra casi el 20% del PIB de país y cerca
del 28% de toda su población.
)
Y esto es tan sólo el comienzo.
Porque a ver, evidentemente, hay zonas más
y menos afectadas, pero Rusia ha bombardeado
y atacado infraestructuras, fábricas y ciudades
a lo largo y ancho de todo el país.
Por ejemplo, los misiles rusos han destruido
o dañado gravemente todas las grandes refinerías
de petróleo.
¿Otro ejemplo?
Algunas de las mayores fábricas del país
se encontraban precisamente en Mariupol y
hoy son escombros.
En total se calcula que los daños provocados
por Rusia tan sólo durante los seis primeros
meses de la guerra se aproximaron a los 100
mil millones de dólares.
Una enorme fortuna para uno de los países
más pobres de Europa.
Y para colmo a esa enorme cifra tenemos además
que sumarle decenas y decenas de miles de
millones que se perderán por el cierre de
las fábricas y las empresas y por todo lo
que costará volver a poner en marcha el país.
Y ni hablemos ya de la pérdida de vidas o
el éxodo masivo de refugiados.
¿El resultado de toda esta salvaje destrucción?
Pues…
Básicamente, el hundimiento de la moneda
de Ucrania, un agujero descomunal en las cuentas
públicas, una inflación por las nubes y
la economía en caída libre.
De hecho, teniendo en cuenta los salarios,
Ucrania se ha vuelto a convertir en el país
más pobre de toda Europa.
Ahora bien, ¿hasta qué punto la crisis amenaza
el futuro de Ucrania?
¿Cuál es exactamente el nivel de destrucción
económica que está sufriendo el país?
¿Qué puede significar para la guerra?
Pues bien, ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LA OTRA CARA DE LA GUERRA)
Rusia ha invadido aproximadamente una quinta
parte de Ucrania, sin embargo, de una forma
u otra la guerra afecta al conjunto del país.
¿Queréis un ejemplo concreto?
Pues fijaos, según un estudio realizado a
primeros de agosto del 2022, el 54% de los
ucranianos tienen seres queridos, familia
o amigos luchando contra el invasor.
Y es que, no lo dudéis, la resistencia a
Rusia se ha convertido en todo un motivo de
orgullo y cohesión nacional.
Sin embargo, las guerras no solo son algo
doloroso y destructivo, también son terriblemente
caras.
Mantener las operaciones de combate no resulta
nada barato, más aún cuando los combates
afectan directamente al tejido económico
del país.
Tomad nota, según las autoridades ucranianas
el PIB se desplomará más de un 33% en 2022.
Una cifra que el Banco Mundial, por ejemplo,
eleva hasta un dramático 45%.
Y el panorama podría ponerse aún peor.
Por ejemplo, prácticamente todos los proyectos
de inversión están parados y luego los principales
bancos de Ucrania se enfrentan a tasas de
morosidad cercanas al 30%.
Una situación que si se mantiene en el tiempo
podría ponerlos contra las cuerdas.
Es decir, podría llevarlos directamente a
la quiebra.
Y claro, evidentemente, cuando una economía
se hunde de tal forma, los ingresos públicos
hacen exactamente lo mismo.
En Ucrania, en términos reales, durante el
mes de junio la recaudación por impuestos
del gobierno se había desplomado casi un
50% respecto al año anterior.
Pero...
La guerra hay que financiarla...
Así que al mismo tiempo que los ingresos
se han reducido a la mitad, se calcula que
el gasto público se ha incrementado más
de un 60%.
¿El resultado?
Un enorme y salvaje boquete en las cuentas
públicas.
Y es que, veréis, a pesar de haber recortado
todo lo no imprescindible, en estos momentos
el gobierno ucraniano apenas está logrando
financiar con impuestos en torno al 30% de
todo el gasto público.
Hablamos de un déficit de unos 5.000 millones
de dólares cada mes.
Una cantidad enorme para un país cuyo PIB
en 2021 apenas fue de 200 mil millones de
dólares.
De hecho, si tenemos en cuenta el desplome
en la actividad económica...
El déficit proyectado para el 2022 fácilmente
podría llegar a superar el 40% del PIB.
Y la pregunta es...
¿Cómo demonios se puede financiar semejante
boquete presupuestario?
Pensad que no solo hablamos de cosas como
las pensiones, el salario de los médicos
- lo que ya de por sí resulta muy importante
dadas las circunstancias - sino también del
propio gasto militar.
Para poder mantener la guerra, Ucrania necesita
financiar este gigantesco déficit.
La pregunta es, ¿Cómo hacerlo?
Y ya se lo que estaréis pensando...
¡Obvio!
Emitiendo deuda como todo el mundo....
Pues sí... pero al mismo tiempo no.
Piénsalo, ¿Estarías dispuesto a invertir
tu dinero en comprar deuda de un país al
borde de la quiebra, con el 20% de su territorio
invadido y que además está en plena guerra
con Rusia?
Pues..
Exactamente eso.
Así que además de emitir deuda, el gobierno
de Zelensky ha tenido que recurrir a otras
medidas.
Por ejemplo, el banco central se ha puesto
como loco a imprimir dinero para financiar
al gobierno.
El problema es que eso, además de disparar
la inflación, está presionando a la baja
el valor de la grivna, la divisa ucraniana.
Lo que a su vez está obligando al banco central
a consumir sus reservas de divisas para que
la moneda local no se desplome del todo.
Concretamente, durante el verano del 2022
el banco central ucraniano ha estado quemando
cada semana un promedio, agarraos a la silla,
de mil millones de dólares
en divisas extranjeras.
A este ritmo en pocos meses el país podría
quedarse sin un sólo dólar.
De ahí que resulta tan importante para Ucrania
reabrir las vías comerciales con el exterior,
incluida, por supuesto, la venta de cereales.
Seguro que habéis oído hablar de ello en
los medios.
Claro que, en el mejor de los casos, esta
actividad apenas generaría 1.000 millones
dólares al mes, una cantidad demasiado pequeña
para compensar todas las fugas que tiene el
país.
Y así es como llegamos a noticias como esta:
(21 de julio del 2022: Ucrania devalua su
moneda, la Grivna, un 25% contra el dólar)
A finales de julio Ucrania decidió devaluar
su moneda un 25% para intentar estabilizar
su divisa haciendo que las exportaciones sean
más baratas y las importaciones más caras.
Y así reducir la salidas de dólares del
país.
(Pero claro, todo esto no son más que parches.
Ni el banco central puede seguir financiando
masivamente al gobierno ni el país puede
seguir quemando sus dólares.
Y desde luego los ucranianos son perfectamente
conscientes de ellos.
La situación es tan delicada que el propio
gobierno le ha pedido a todas las empresas
públicas del país que retrasen el pago de
su deuda incluso cuando tengan dinero para
pagarla.
El objetivo es frenar con ello la salida de
dólares a cualquier precio.
Y, de hecho, esto es algo que también ha
hecho el propio gobierno que ha acordado con
sus principales acreedores retrasar un año
todos los pagos de la deuda pública ucraniana.)
Y por si esto fuera poco, aún hay más.
Otro problema al que se enfrenta este país
es precisamente el invierno.
Ucrania tiene actualmente el nivel de almacenamiento
de gas más bajo de toda Europa.
Por ejemplo, se calcula que a finales de julio
apenas tenía llena el 22% de su capacidad
de almacenamiento.
Una cantidad totalmente insuficiente para
enfrentarse al invierno ucraniano, un invierno
condenadamente frío.
Pues bien, los cálculos de la empresa nacional
de gas apuntan a que como mínimo el país
tendrá que comprar 5.000 millones de metros
cúbicos de gas.
Algo que a los precios actuales del gas en
Europa puede tener un coste de más de 10.000
millones de dólares.
(Y ahí tampoco termina todo.
El país también tendrá que gastar importantes
recursos para mantener funcionando la red
eléctrica, que ha sido muy dañada por los
rusos.
Tanto en lo que respecta a las centrales como
a los propios cables o centrales de transformación.
Lo que por supuesto engordará aún más la
factura.
Pero es que, claro, un país simple y llanamente
no puede funcionar sin energía.)
Amigos, amigas, lo miremos por dónde lo miremos,
la situación económica en Ucrania es crítica
incluso aunque algunas cosas hayan mejorado
respecto a los momentos iniciales de la invasión:
Sí, la mayoría de las empresas del país
han reabierto sus puertas;
la oferta de gasolina, de diesel y de otros
combustibles se está restableciendo gracias
a que más de 300 camiones cisterna cruzan
cada día la frontera desde Europa;
El país también le ha comenzado a vender
electricidad a la Unión Europea;
La supresión de aranceles y de exigencias
reglamentarias varias por parte de los países
aliados está contribuyendo a reactivar las
exportaciones;
y, además, la resistencia del ejército ha
hecho que el grueso de las cosechas pudieran
llevarse a cabo.
Pero a pesar de todo ello, el desplome del
PIB, el cierre de las grandes fábricas, el
creciente déficit comercial y sobre todo
el gigantesco boquete en las cuentas públicas
hacen que la situación sea crítica.
Así que entonces, tenemos que regresar a
la pregunta clave que nos hacíamos antes:
¿Cómo demonios espera Ucrania pagar todas
las facturas?
Pues, ¿sabéis qué?
Justo aquí es donde entran en juego los aliados
occidentales.
Atentos.
T2 (LA SUPERVIVENCIA DE UCRANIA)
Hasta ahora el gobierno ucraniano ha tomado
un montón de medidas contrarreloj para intentar
estabilizar la situación:
Por ejemplo, introdujo severos controles de
capitales; intervino el tipo de cambio; metió
la tijera a un montón de gastos; garantizó
los depósitos bancarios; eliminó y cambió
algunos impuestos; se elevaron los tipos de
interés, y así un largo etcétera, etcétera.
Sin embargo, tal y como hemos visto la situación
es tan complicada que por sí misma Ucrania
tiene poco que hacer.
Así que justo aquí es donde entra en juego
la comunidad internacional.
Queridos amigos, a Estados Unidos, a la Unión
Europea, al Reino Unido y al resto de aliados
no les basta con entregar equipos militares
a Ucrania.
Si quieren que este país tenga éxito en
su feroz resistencia contra Rusia, también
tienen que ocuparse de la otra cara de la
guerra.
Y, ¿sabéis qué?
Eso es exactamente - al menos por ahora - lo
que están haciendo.
Fijaos en este gráfico:
Aproximadamente el gobierno de Ucrania cubre
algo menos de un tercio de todo su gasto público
con impuestos, un importe similar lo consigue
recurriendo al banco central y luego los aliados
ponen el resto.
Una ayuda esta que se ha convertido ya con
mucha diferencia en la principal fuente de
financiación del déficit público.
Una ayuda que, además, se espera que se incremente
durante los próximos meses para que Kiev
pueda dejar de imprimir dinero.
(En total, entre el 24 de febrero del 2022,
que fue el día que comenzó la invasión,
y comienzos del mes de agosto, el gobierno
de Ucrania recibió más de 12.000 millones
de dólares de Estados Unidos, la Unión Europea,
Alemania, Japón y Canadá entre otros países
aliados.
12.000 millones en forma de subvenciones,
donaciones y préstamos en condiciones muy
pero que muy ventajosas destinados integramente
a financiar el gasto público del gobierno
de Zelensky.)
Y no solo eso.
Estos mismos aliados se han comprometido a
desembolsar otros 20.000 millones durante
los próximos meses tan sólo para apoyar
las finanzas del gobierno.
Y, ojo, porque si a esta cantidad le añadimos
la ayuda humanitaria y la ayuda militar total,
la cifra que hasta ahora los aliados se han
comprometido a desembolsar supera los 80.000
millones de dólares.
Tal y como podéis ver en este gráfico, la
mayor cantidad, con mucha diferencia, corresponde
a Estados Unidos.
Esto es mucho, muchísimo dinero.
Hablamos de una histórica movilización de
recursos para intentar conseguir que el agresor,
en este caso Rusia, lo pague con creces en
el campo de batalla.
Al fin y al cabo no sólo se trata de Ucrania.
En esta guerra está en juego la capacidad
de los países libres para defenderse del
chantaje de una tiranía como la de Vladimir
Putin.
C1 ("La lucha de Ucrania es nuestra lucha".
Morten Bødskov, Ministro de Defensa de Dinamarca)
Sin embargo, lo siento, pero tampoco esto
resulta suficiente.
La guerra en Ucrania no parece que se vaya
a terminar en el corto plazo.
Si las democracias occidentales realmente
quieren que Ucrania consiga defenderse de
la agresión de las huestes de Putin, tienen
que hacer un esfuerzo mucho mayor.
Tienen que comprometer más recursos tanto
militares como técnicos y financieros, y
sobre todo tienen que agilizar los desembolsos.
Es decir, tienen que soltar más rápido la
pasta y tienen que hacerlo con la garantía
de que el dinero llegue a dónde tiene que
llegar.
[Ya os hemos contado que Ucrania nunca se
ha caracterizado por tener un estado de derecho
de primera o por ser el país más transparente
del mundo.]
Pero de una forma u otra el dinero tiene que
llegar y tiene que llegar más rápido.
Entre otras cosas porque la situación económica
de Ucrania es absolutamente crítica.
Y es que esta es, amigos, la otra cara de
la guerra.
El otro frente de batalla en el que se está
trabajando a destajo aunque rara vez salga
por la tele.
Claro que titulares como este parecen indicar
otra cosa:
(Las potencias de Europa no dieron a Ucrania
nuevas promesas militares en julio, según
muestran los datos
El apoyo militar de Europa a Ucrania ha ido
disminuyendo desde abril, según datos del
Instituto Kiel.)
A ver, el compromiso de Estados Unidos, Reino
Unido y la mayoría de países del este de
Europa parece firme, sin embargo no está
claro que se pueda decir lo mismo de países
como Francia o Alemania.
La crisis energética está comenzando a castigarlos
y la sensación que existe es que estos países
estarían encantados con la firma de un alto
el fuego.
Aunque solo sea para seguir recibiendo gas
de Rusia mientras encuentran alternativas.
Sin embargo, eso podría ser un gran error.
La propia Casa Blanca lo tiene muy claro,
en esta guerra está en juego mucho más que
la soberanía ucraniana sobre el Donbass o
el sur del país.
Está en juego sobre todo la supremacía del
mundo libre.
Y también está en juego lo que otros dictadores
como Xi Jinping puedan aprender sobre lo que
nunca deben hacer...
Por ejemplo en Taiwán.
Además, Rusia ha ocupado o mantiene bajo
asedio no sólo muchas de las principales
zonas industriales, sino también una parte
muy importante de los recursos naturales del
país, lo que podría dificultar y mucho la
reconstrucción de Ucrania.
Algunas estimaciones apuntan a que Rusia se
habría hecho con más del 60% de los depósitos
de carbón del país, con el 42% de los yacimientos
de metales y con una tercera parte de todos
los depósitos de tierras raras y otros minerales
críticos como el litio.
Y todo eso por no pensar cuál sería realmente
el futuro de Ucrania si Rusia no es claramente
derrotada.
C2 ("Ucrania no solo habría perdido gran
parte de su territorio y sus recursos, sino
que sería constantemente vulnerable a otro
ataque de Rusia [..] Nadie en su sano juicio
o una empresa privada, invertiría en el resto
de Ucrania si esto se convirtiera en un conflicto
congelado".
Jacob Kirkegaard, miembro del Instituto Peterson
de Economía Internacional con sede en Washington.)
Y, ojo, porque hasta ahora sólo hemos hablado
de lo que Ucrania necesita para seguir en
pie, luchando contra los rusos.
Pero lo cierto es que a medio y largo plazo
el país necesitará mucho, muchísimo más
dinero.
Hablamos según las estimaciones existentes
de cientos y cientos de miles de millones
de dólares para volver a poner en pie la
economía, la industria, las ciudades y las
infraestructuras ucranianas.
La guerra está siendo devastadora.
Eso sí, todo esto puede parecernos mucho
dinero y, ciertamente lo es.
Sin embargo, tenemos que tener en cuenta que
el PIB acumulado de los países aliados supera
los 50 billones de dólares.
Es decir, que tienen músculo más que suficiente
para hacer frente a toda la factura.
Así que, no sé, visto de esta forma, el
precio a pagar a cambio de derrotar a Putin
y demostrarle al mundo que conviene ser aliados
de los países libres parece bastante asumible.
En cualquier caso, esto ya es algo interpretable.
Lo que está claro es que la Guerra en Ucrania
va mucho más allá de Ucrania.
Este país es dependiente militar y financieramente
de Occidente.
Y si ha conseguido frenar a la maquinaria
de guerra rusa se debe sobre todo a su tenaz
resistencia pero también al compromiso demostrado
por sus aliados occidentales.
Pero aún así la situación es crítica,
hace falta más dinero y hace falta ya.
Si esto no se produce la economía ucraniana
podría irse a pique por completo, lo que
haría prácticamente imposible mantener las
operaciones de combate.
Sin producción, sin dinero, sin suministros
y con una crisis galopante poco podrían hacer.
Y desde luego, si queréis nuestra opinión,
en VisualPolitik lo tenemos muy claro: Hay
que apoyar a Ucrania cueste lo que cueste.
Este es uno de esos momentos históricos en
los que el mundo libre tiene que imponerse
a las tiranías.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Hasta qué punto crees que los aliados financiarán
el esfuerzo de guerra de Ucrania?
¿Hasta dónde llega su compromiso?
¿Crees que veremos pronto un alto el fuego?
Déjanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios y
ya sabéis, si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros
a VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima